greetings from podcast Ville it's Monday
the 13th of [ __ ] January 2020 and
you're still sitting there thinking to
myself what am I gonna do with my life
I'll tell you what the [ __ ] you're gonna
do you know listen to the church or
what's happened now kick this
[ __ ] me Oh Lee Oh ain't no music
no more they won't let us on Spotify
without music he's my man Tom Rhodes I
got the [ __ ]
it's Monday morning the [ __ ] you want
from me oh wait Joey how are you my
brother brother great time at the comedy
school Saturday night oh my god that was
probably one of the best lineups it's me
I think that's probably one of the best
sets I've ever done in the comedy so you
are on fire I crushed it one far and
then Neal Brennan Neal Brennan this oh
my god he's got like so much brilliant
new material about that dude's a writer
and a hat that's it's you know it's it's
impressive to see you know how he turns
it over and his thought process you know
it's a lot of philosophy and social
commentary just absolutely brilliant did
you hang out for the rest of the night
oh yeah a little bit and I watched your
set you crushed it you're doing new
material I've never seen you do before
you gotta try it
I love it you know that's the exciting
thing about playing there is like you
see the best of the best and it makes
you want to raise your game you know
that's why I kept going there because
you see what other guys are doing you're
like I got a I got that's how hard I
gotta be working so it's a constant
rotation [ __ ] work wildlife good man and
I did a show last Wednesday in Palm
Springs for some old white people I
don't know why I took this gig and I ate
one of the biggest [ __ ] sandwiches I've
eaten in quite a few years and you know
they just said don't do any political
stuff so I was like okay cool but
apparently some of my like regular jokes
were too hard for these people and so
that set I did at The Comedy Store on
Saturday you know like if you have like
a bad set as a comedian that just stays
in your head and you can't erase it
until you crush it so like I was washing
that stink off me
on that stage every joke that killed I
was getting in the crevices and was it a
private eye
I was just I guess it was just a gig
that I had no business being a part of
did the promoter make a bad call I'm
either ah yeah what happens in those
gigs I like I don't take privates it
wasn't a private gig I don't do private
gigs either and I noticed you know I
don't do cruise ships I don't do I don't
want to play anywhere where there's old
white people that are gonna get upset by
anything you know well that's everywhere
now yeah thanks everyone
yeah that you know people are going out
people are going out with the whatever
but it has slowed down a little bit over
the last couple of weeks I thank God for
Ricky Gervais is going off Sunday night
to let people know that you've still got
a voice okay we still got a voice you
know what if they want to can't see your
TV show we don't have one if they want
to cancel my Twitter account
I'll keep telling jokes right you know
so we're in a society right now that
we're not gonna stop the comedy stores
not gonna shut down right you know the
other clubs are gonna shut down so you
have to say what that that's what comedy
is it's the truth it's the truth so
that's what are you scared of hearing
the [ __ ] comedy is a dark room where
adults go to hear the uncomfortable
truths the truth yeah you know when I
saw those people at whatever the Grammys
the Golden Globes
they were [ __ ] moving in that chair
that means a comic did his job that
means a comic did his job and the people
that had a sense of humor they were
laughing they didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
you know it's it's what happens is
you're at a table with six guys Tom
Hanks is at that table I'm not allowed
to laugh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you Tom Hanks at
that long never used it was it tall
enough to write the time you spent in an
amusement park
yeah he's not tall enough to ride the
road olicity Hoffman license plate all
that is so funny that's brilliant [ __ ]
and then at the end he said something
that you want to tell people every day
and you can't because that's all I know
I live my life I know it that half of
these people walk around with one foot
in and one foot out
and then they they brag to you about the
one for them about how good of people
they are they donate the [ __ ] this
they do this but then they have this
other leg and this [ __ ] destruction
mode where you know their employees are
jumping out [ __ ] windows you know
[ __ ] it the land about Isis have an
Australian service yeah and you know
what and then that line what was the
Jeffrey Epstein line that was funny - oh
so now he said he said something man and
did some others I think your own private
plane but look even the [ __ ] Isis
line the ISIS line is a joke but do you
people listening at the house it's not a
joke these people will either scab off a
dog's knee they don't give a [ __ ] they
really don't give a [ __ ] you know he
made a Harvey Weinstein joke or
something there's there's that was it he
said he was like something about Harvey
Weinstein and Jeffrey Epstein wasn't it
what Epstein was he said that the UH he
said that he'd rather be this is the
last time he's doing it that you'd much
rather be watching that Netflix is
everybody stuff ever be streaming
television des movies that everybody
streaming everybody's talking about
Netflix that his show is on Netflix
about a guy who's thinking it killed
himself after his wife dies of cancer he
goes spoiler he doesn't kill himself
just like Jeffrey Epstein that was it
and he goes ah I know I know he was your
friend I don't care it's your own flight
here tonight and that's the truth you
know listen even in comedy okay you were
around for tennis oh we're not I was a
kid I mean I was in high school and I
okay okay so you weren't and I went and
saw no no no but I saw Kinnison when I
was 16 I was such a fan I bought a
ticket by myself I went to the
Tupperware theater in Orlando and sat
there and watched but my point is that
if you knew Tennyson like I didn't know
Kennison but I see it now in smaller
scales there's always that one rich guy
at the comic store
that's Hispanics a filthy rich nobody
knows about it he just goes up there and
since his Comrie isn't up to par he
becomes something else he has to lure
them in with something else you know and
when you could see that Jeffrey Epstein
was just one of those guys and Hobnobs
against big-time people and then I'll
take my jet come to my Island you know
it became like a [ __ ] joke there's
people like that that creep into your
circle and they're called one of those
people that if you eat cake they give
you cake
well those neighborhoods Able's they're
really like [ __ ] enablers like you
know and it was we're definitely sanity
struck a quarter of those people Jeffrey
Epstein would be at all those parties
mingling they all know who the [ __ ] he
was you know they all know what was
going on when Harvey Weinstein when he
was going they all know but they didn't
give a [ __ ] nobody raised their [ __ ]
hand we live in a town where if we raise
our hand we lose our career we care more
about our pocketbook you don't think
anybody know Jeff Harvey Weinstein was
[ __ ] broad to get his dick sucked for
movies you're gonna look me in the face
and say that you know those particular
type of guys they're like frat boy the
guys that you go to their parties and
their girlfriends are there but they're
in a circle on their own don't get about
the chicks they're banging on the side
and all that [ __ ] that's what those
Jeffrey Epstein parties were as soon as
you walked in Jeffery you put his arm
around you right in front of your wife
walk your way and go excuse me ally just
talk to him and you and she's like oh
aren't I impressed and also he's like
with you see the 16 year old [ __ ] I got
away to be in the back to that I knew
guys like that I didn't hang out with
them because of those reasons but I know
people like that
did I just creep that's how they got
cool you know invite a bunch of 40 year
old was to [ __ ] a bunch of 18 year old
makes you cooler than that if I called
you right now let's come over to the
house and you came over to my house I
had three 18 year olds in the back of a
couple lines a coke and all sudden you
get there and you're like
who are they and they're like we're
gonna be in Joey's no movie no ain't no
move ha ha what move are you talking you
look at me later really yeah we're
talking to Leonardo DiCaprio right now
as we speak in there like oh we're gonna
work with Leo
come on doing wine take the top slow
let's get the party started
that's what it is you gonna tell me you
didn't know about those parties you
don't look me into Matt Damon then know
about those Brad Pitt didn't know about
those laying out of the Capitol and know
about those I'm not mad at them I would
have probably gone for those two or
taking the 20 million dollars of the
movie what you know I'm saying so what
we live in the you know and the worst
you know I used to love to call I'll
tell you God Marc Babbitt because we've
I love davit and Babbitt worked you and
I together you and I met because Babbitt
booked us together but I got into a
point with battle where I would just
call him to say hello and I would get
off the phone
I would never ask him for work because I
always wanted people even today in
Connolly there's a guy that gave me my
first Wednesday in Braille his name is
Dan
he's our improv organization but guess
what but I still call him once a month
because I know no other comedians call
like that yeah once you're you're out of
a position to put money in my pocket we
don't need you no more I think that's a
horrible
I think Wilma whoever raised you did a
bad job yeah I think that and I don't do
that with people even after somebody
leaves the club if they took care of me
I try to call him once a [ __ ] year I
still call the bowler from San Jose they
used to have a manage it on the weekends
he was a professional Bowl he just gave
up moved to Vegas I still check him with
him on see it to let him know that all
those spots he gave me weren't in vain I
told you before we started recording you
know like a year ago at this time I was
going through my divorce I had just
broken up my wife and I had just broken
up and you're one of the few friends
that called me like every week how you
doing
you're not thinking about drinking are
you you know and and I think it was just
a couple of friends that reached out to
me into that period when I was in the
toilet emotion
nobody knows I've never had to doubt
your friendship since the day we met
nobody knows about divorce until you've
gone through a divorce nobody knows
about losing a cat till you've gone
through losing a cat nobody knows what
it goes through losing a parent or you
lose a parent so you become empathetic
so as soon as somebody says to you even
if you [ __ ] hate that person Tom
Roach somebody comes to you and says
that person wants their mother changes
everything
you will call that person go whatever
problem we had between us it's over for
right now I'm calling you to tell you
I'm really sorry about your mother it's
funny I did that with what louis c.k a
few months ago and then I hadn't talked
to the guy in years I heard his mom died
I sent him a message and we traded some
texts you know it's amazing that people
once you get written off in this town
you get written off and I don't like
that because my friends never wrote me
up even when I was doing [ __ ] time
that it wrote me off but that's
something that's taught that's something
that's taught to people from you that
comes from above you know I'm saying
here like I said you work with a comedy
guy comedy guy tation you know you look
at Ronda Rousey's rise I heard there was
a guy that went to Ronda Rousey unlocked
ruinous enough and took pictures of her
and helped her and promoted her and for
the first manager right her first
manager that all this [ __ ] and one day
she fired him with a text message warm
one the career was over yes she might be
wrestling and she might be rich but
she's got that stink that somebody
genuinely tried to help her and he spit
in his face that stink stays with you
for a long time that spit comes back to
haunt you later on so somebody went out
of their way to get you started uh three
yards came along and you dumped that guy
sign with three arts and that's it
people do that in this town all the time
they don't realize you know it's so
weird I got into comedy to [ __ ] do
comedy I ended up becoming a man by
comedy because comedy was like my
religious belief it helped me become a
command that's how I feel comedy is my
religion and with motherly party it's my
religion yes it's my religion
and it's who you know and I tell people
all the time it's not like me and Rogan
talked every day about stupid [ __ ] we
don't we really don't twenty-two years
but when him and I get together we just
talk about the dynamic which is comedy
what he's been doing what's not working
you know how he's been doing it
differently there's a whole science to
it and even if our friendship is
connected by that that alone right there
you know like that bond we have you and
I have since day one but I was talking
about Babbitt and one day Babbitt
calling me back and go hey don't you
want to work a week in my club
and I go yeah but we'll get to that when
it's time because I treated Booker's
like girls I treated Booker's like you
would treat a woman that watch you you
don't chase a woman that watch it you
give them a little bit then you pull
back and I see what the pieces for and
they'll come to you like [ __ ] a
pigeon comes to a [ __ ] little worm
because you know it's like when you walk
into a room and there's a hot chick
there you don't react her but 20 guys
reacted to it that chick isn't concerned
about the 20 guys they reacted to her
she's concerned about why Tom Rhodes
didn't look my way not the Tom Rhodes
means anything but that guy didn't look
my way do you know I'm saying mm-hmm
exact guy didn't go Wow look at your
tits you just walk right past and said
go [ __ ] yourself you got to these just
like everybody else you dumb [ __ ] so
it's so weird how that works with Tom
Lee bookings like and just friendships
and how you have to work Booker's
relationship sometimes it's coamo it was
going on nothing like what you said
about you know comedy taught you be a
man and you know you're empathetic
you're a great friend you know I've
never had to doubt your friendship I had
an incredible thing happened to me you
know a year ago at this time my wife
moved out New Year's Eve last year not
this one that just passed so last
December was really rough I took my mom
to Israel
of December last year and then I was
home for the holidays in Orlando and I
was flying back to Los Angeles on
Christmas Eve my flight was at 7:00 a.m.
from the Orlando Airport and I'm
checking in I'm the the first person in
line there's people with the Delta
agents and this guy comes up to me and
he says can my family and I cut in front
of you my brother just committed suicide
we have to get to Hawaii and I turned
around and I just saw this family
destroyed they were just they were just
crying and the dad could barely stand up
his name is Dean he's a fan of yours
hello Dean and well I I knew that
feeling when my sister died of cancer I
I didn't know a human being could cry
that much I had like hyperventilating
crying I would be exhausted
from crying so much physically exhausted
where I couldn't even stand up and I saw
this family and I let him go through and
it just like put everything into
perspective for me I'm going through a
divorce I thought I was having a hard
time feeling all sorry for myself I'll
never be loved again and I see this
family and I knew instantly what I know
that feeling I've been there and I
realized going through a divorce isn't
the worst level of pain you could
experience and I wouldn't even classify
it as pain it's it's an inconvenience so
I talked about it on my podcast and this
friend of mine that I grew up with guy I
played baseball with Chuck Bowman whose
son is a fan of yours he listens to this
show he contacted me and said hey man I
know that family they the the the son
was a soldier you know he had PTSD and
he's I know these people so through my
buddy Chuck I got in touch with his
family with the dad so last year over
the course of a year we've we've traded
emails and stuff and then when I was
just home at Christmas in Orlando or
Oviedo I went and met this family and
it's a year later they're doing much
better I mean you'll never recover from
something like that
I'll never get over my dad and my
sister's death there's just degrees of
better as time goes on but like I feel
bonded to these people like I feel like
they're my my brothers
I feel related to these people you know
just because we I feel like I somehow
was in on this private family moment
that was probably the worst day of their
lives I know the day my sister died was
the worst day of my life you know it's
so funny how I go you know and I text
away texts with them the dad and the son
you still do yeah I mean I just met him
yeah I mean I feel closer to these two
guys than I do my own brothers who are
more hunts you know like I feel I feel
blessed to know these people and they
were all military people they've all
served you know I'm from Oviedo Florida
I graduated in 85 the Dean the father he
graduated from Oviedo in 1974 when I was
there it was like a small citrus farming
village it was one traffic light and the
tractor crossing you know so I couldn't
imagine Oviedo Oviedo Florida it's like
17 miles east of Orlando so it was a
citrus farming town and then Orlando
expanded they built a circular highway
around Orlando and now it's kind of like
a highway exit there's a target and the
Chili's and all that other support
suburban American [ __ ] yeah it's really
funny how we uh you meet people on the
road sometimes a shock you also hear
little stories on the road like I'm
probably in my phone I probably have 20
people who I keep in touch it from the
road that just touch you sometimes the
road could be a [ __ ] lonely place and
somebody just talks to hear from just
talks to you not even from a comedy
perspective and then they find out later
your economic and we get to talk and
they call my uncle likes you or whatever
the [ __ ] it is you have this
relationship with them for life you know
yeah you know I have a witness in
Chicago Bobby Sheeran in Texas you know
you meet these people
add so much pizzazz you know he spooky
in Texas you know she's got my back and
he's got all these different people that
we've met through the years even through
this [ __ ] funny thing called the
podcast and these wires yeah you know
and it's just it teaches you a different
degree of part of even on the internet
teaches you different degree of of
empathy you know I would hate to feel
like I felt when my cat died I felt bad
and I write I really wanted to write
something about Superbad and put him up
and the reach was overwhelming you know
people get it people get that that one
line you know I believe that you have to
make somebody's day every day oh that
that's the key to life if you want a
great life forget about giving somebody
money sucking somebody's [ __ ]
it's just making somebody smile once a
day a call just making somebody's day
whatever it could be whatever it could
be given some even I instill in my
daughter but that's the most important
thing of your day is making somebody's
day and everything else falls into poor
I always say it's it's so easy to to
change somebody's life for the better
you know I guy when I see like more
famous comedians and like their fans
they'll come on them you know and
they'll be like give them the cold
shoulder and stuff I always find that
ingratitude
well this there's two types of walking
up on somebody also this is there's
twenty ten different we could go on 20
different things according to that
because years ago we were kids there was
a thing with George Michael George
Michael went on public record and said
leave me the [ __ ] alone I don't want to
talk to no but he's also [ __ ] say
hello you know just would all [ __ ] I say
hello to me I was a George Michael fan
that by his music and him by his music I
like the videos you know that's what you
get all that [ __ ] with the models and
stuff but I felt that I felt it to be
rude yeah I felt it to be rude I felt
that they even be rude
okay so let's say you're not coming
let's say I have a TV show let's say I
was not a stand-up comic and I have a TV
show and every week you can't take a
half hour out of your life to watch the
show I could give you a minute out of my
life to say hello how you doing whatever
there's a thin line but there's a thin
line how are you I'm I'm over five were
stuck on an elevator
hey that episode about whatever really
in the home with me I just lost my
mother okay that's where it ends that's
great I love I love people coming to the
shows and I love talking to people after
this shows it's the expectations you
know I can't be at a restaurant my
daughter and you come up to me and say
it's blue cheese with wings or go [ __ ]
your mother in front of my daughter
it's happened oh it's happened you know
you can't manhandle me you know I'm
saying like come up to me with six guys
and go yo you [ __ ] I can't deal
with that there's always a place at a
time for everything and you have to
decide as a human being what's more
important do I go up to Tom Rhodes who
I'm a fan of at the airport online with
200 people waiting before you board a
plane kind of just clumped Ian's go
Tom's I love what you do here I heard
John Whitney come his podcast said [ __ ]
was funny or you come up to me at 6:00
a.m. when I'm half mummified from the
night before and I'm gonna ask me about
episode 648 of Joe Rogan when I quoted
that Ruben blades is gonna beat up
chichi Ramirez in a game of [ __ ]
ping-pong and then they want to ask you
for a picture on the line there's 200
people here you're gonna blow up my
[ __ ] [ __ ] in front of 200 people at
6:00 in the morning when you know I'm a
[ __ ] stoner you know I'm high as a
kite you know I'm gonna get
uncomfortable you know I'm saying yeah
you know when I when I so many people
that's the type of [ __ ] that bothers me
then you go to the shows you go to these
shows and you pull up around the back
and there's these six geeks with
everything you ever did print it out
print an athlete what army sign it make
it sell it on eBay
yeah and I'm supposed to feel bad you
know I'm saying like that's a different
level of me feeling bad I really don't
mind giving them an autograph or two hey
everybody needs a dollar but these guys
will sit there and just keep saying can
you sign this
can you sign this again so if you sign
one you gotta sign 20 you know before we
show last night when you're at the
Comedy Store Tom Rhodes is on a stage
Tom Rhodes is doing his best I moved to
a feet over can I get a picture I can't
give you a picture because you're
disrupting I'm disrespecting Tom Rhodes
if I walked you a [ __ ] if I'm doing
the Improv embrace and the show starts
and Lee's hosting and I walked out into
the front and a guy grabs me while he's
on stage and he goes can I get a picture
and I'd take a picture that
disrespectfully even if I'm the
headliner
that's Lee's 15 minutes what the [ __ ] am
i they take a picture in the show room
when Lee's on Fringe so there's
different degrees of of everything you
as the fan or my family member I mean
that showmanship and even when like a
comedian will get offstage and then
start talking with someone loudly in the
back I want to [ __ ] this back on the
mouth yeah I hate that I want to smack
them in the mouth take the comic and
take them downstairs and go around the
[ __ ] bed and yeah at the Comedy Store
we get loud in the hallway sometimes
mm-hmm
we go off in the hallway sometimes you
know whatever I catch myself and I try
to keep a little pain you want respect
you have to give respect in this world
and when it comes to pictures and all
that [ __ ] at restaurants and whatever
you know I've had people pay for meals
for me and I'll get up and walk over to
the table shake their hand hug them take
a picture and then I'll get the [ __ ] out
of there but don't come over to my table
yelling and screaming I'm gonna have my
wife and my kids there ray
it's just there's always a fine line
that you as the human being has to
decide on you don't know how many times
I've seen somebody who blows me out of
the water like that an actor or
something the last thing on my mind is
asking for a picture I was on an
elevator with Lou Reed once and I loved
the read love them yeah and I think the
1989 album New York I think probably
saved my life when I was living in New
York that year and struggling and
everything and I was on an elevator with
him once and I'm such a fan didn't say a
word to him so I didn't bother him let
him enjoy his 16 floors and silence
sometimes a wink is as good as a nod to
a blind horse you know why I have that
faces out why be like everybody else
be original put your hand on the sarazar
like what you do yeah and sometimes they
won't put the hand down and now you just
learned about the guy you'd learned
where he really stands you know I've got
a thousand people I put my hands on
they'll put there and that's the end of
the conversation I don't even want a
[ __ ] picture because we were at the
[ __ ] Airport because we're at a
restaurant because I'm saying yeah if
not now I'm gonna have ten other people
coming to take pictures of you I
remember so six she six years ago
January 1st this year was when I blacked
out and busted my head open in
Philadelphia and and I haven't drank
alcohol since then and you know there
was like two years after my dad and my
sister died where I had stopped drinking
for pleasure
and I really started to get that
alcoholic white guy booze face with the
bulbous nose and everything and when I
busted my head open in Philadelphia I
was just so wasted I blacked out and
fell off this bar stool like a tree
busted my head open on a tile floor had
to go to the emergency room and I got I
got six stitches on my forehead and I
had a black eye and I had to do this
morning radio show the next morning and
III had to go I had like I got out of
the emergency room I had time to go to
my hotel for like probably thirty
minutes before I had to go straight to
this radio show
and I looked like a train wreck and this
girl who worked on the show she goes I'm
a fan can I take a pic can we have a
picture together and I thought I would
take a picture with you any day but
today I just can't do it today either
[ __ ] Frankenstein stitches and a
black eye and you know I just like this
you know huge you know revelation in my
life that I needed the [ __ ] dial it
back on the drugs and alcohol you know
and not the day for a picture know this
it's just really weird how the whole
picture thing has I don't want I was
looked at a couple weeks ago play the
club and they charge ten dollars for
pictures what I found out afterward the
club was and I had I don't want to
embarrass and I had 800 people there and
you know usually I like taking pictures
of people it's one show I was like why
aren't people taking pictures because
that was charging ten bucks the [ __ ]
thing Jesus so it kind of picks me off
you know fits in but if I have two shows
what people seemed on the fluffy got a
lot of heat for this Gabriel just
Gabriel stop going out in between shows
he realized after fifteen years it took
too much energy from him to do the two
shows once you talked to a thousand
people then you got to rest for ten
minutes and then go back up then do it
all over again it's kind of tough I try
that's why this year I'm kind of down to
only one shows and theaters so I could
get back out there and talk to the
people I don't want to smoke power yet I
want to heroin wait you but I want to
take a picture you know see what's on
your mind you know I've always enjoyed
that many new people seeing what's on
their mind and normally only going back
but I something that what you guys are
talking about at the beginning where if
you go through a divorce oh you go
through a death and it's hard and and
the thing that struck me was how it's
like it's always when you lose something
has gone through those things helped you
live more in the moment like to like
appreciate stuff while you have
I mean it realized you realize your
immortality when you lose family members
I mean every life just seems like this
endless ribbon that keeps on flowing and
then I mean nobody's prepared to lose a
parent or a child it definitely and then
like it still took me a couple years
like when I busted my head open I
realized that you know I was put on this
earth to do great things and the best
way I could honor the memory of my
father and my sister was by being the
greatest comedian and greatest human
being that I could possibly be you know
so I think it definitely sharpened the
lens focus in that regard you know I
tell you when people when I see somebody
on social media man I want my parent or
whatever or somebody will hit me up and
say I lost a parent it hurts and I go
listen you want to ease the pain here it
is become the man of a woman that they
want to get me yeah
if you become the man a woman they
wanted you to be the pain will disappear
it I'm lying here it never disappears
that's true but I think you you could
agree you're absolutely right so often
yeah because you never have you'll never
get over something I just celebrated my
mother's 40th 40 years ago we buried it
November 8th well and honestly it didn't
hurt as much as I thought it would hurt
but pain plays with you ain't plays for
you pain hits you when you least
expected it's like a toothache you don't
say it's it's it's so he didn't hit me
that whole week I thought about it I
look at Campbell I prayed for her I
thought about the night she died how
[ __ ] that was 40 [ __ ] years ago but
then I realized something else
I made it 40 years without her I didn't
the day library there I'm like I got
about a year before I can make it
without her so I proved myself wrong it
was such a [ __ ] that's where the
power comes from
you know there's a song by Lionel Richie
called
I think he did it with the common laws
it opens up it's a piano thing and he
says a sale on sale on that's a piano
opening mornings just a moment away but
I'm with you once again you laughed at
me you said you've never needed me I
wonder if you need me now it's it's it's
it is the most gorgeous words you could
hear in the beginning of a song it's a
it's a piano thing just the piano and he
and I remember that every time that I
hear that song I think about the
emptiness had in my stomach when my
mother died when I first got divorced
when I first got divorced and you wake
up in the morning and you used to seeing
that person next to you it really does
something to you yeah man like this time
last year I spent most days alone in my
apartment crying yeah and then my friend
Joey Diaz called hey hey Joe I still
remember waking up and just hearing that
song you know Here I am I'm mourning
again and I'm without you once again you
know opening the dump today with that
line brushing your teeth up in the
shower and eventually the the song one
away after like four years
I didn't hear this song in my head
anymore but it's just so you know and I
and I also pink pain piggybacks pain so
if you lose a sister in 2009 and just as
you're starting to get over it use your
father in 211 there's the other way
around but that's exactly what it's like
taking the scab off the thing I hadn't
gotten over the death of my hair yeah
you even get off the husband I didn't
think I could handle that and then
[ __ ] my darling little sister I'll
tell you
don't look at it very much I think
that's cool like that song gave you
strength
you know the Tupac song dear mama oh it
helps me yeah if you can make it through
tonight there's a brighter day that I
[ __ ] love that song but an odd thing I
don't look at it too much anymore when
sometimes the website sticks but and I
don't know I read about this something I
think I was in England I read about this
it's a website called morning breakfast
radio.com and what they do on the
website there's a picture of the globe
and it shows where the Sun is rising all
around the world and it says the Sun is
always rising somewhere and what this
website does it's a radio thing and
it'll grab a half-hour snippets of
morning radio shows or morning radio
from all over the world so like you
could look at it any time of the day
like right now the Sun is probably
rising in in in Australia or Africa and
you go on there and you'll hear I got
one day like one Sunday I listen to like
a garden show in Perth Australia
another time I listen to like I listened
to it roll across Africa one one one day
and it's cool man and it's like it's
like a half hour like because all these
radio stations are streaming online now
so I don't know how they have it set up
but it grabs so I always thought like if
you're like in a really dark fucked-up
place it's good concept to remember that
you know it might be dark where you are
right now but the Sun is is rising
somewhere in the world I know that's
kind of cheesy but when you're in the
toilet going through some difficult [ __ ]
it's good to remember that you know in
Tahiti people are going to work right
now or you know [ __ ] Morocco they're
starting to you know bang out the pita
bread
Lee's question before was interesting
because he does it does it put things
into perspective yes it does yes it does
you know next Sunday night they having a
thing at the store for Brody oh yeah I'm
gonna go to the you take a look I like
Brody okay whether you were tight with
Brody or you weren't Tyra Pro didn't
care for brother you love bro you like
did you look at a guy like Brody you
wake up at 8 in the morning you got all
the opportunities in the world but you
tend to turn the [ __ ] TV on and sit
dental - and they have to know go
[ __ ] wait Brody up and ask him if he
had the chance if he'd wake up at night
and sit in front of the TV till 2
o'clock go ask him with what he just saw
the love room response he saw him having
a wherever the [ __ ] he is death
everything that goes backwards put
something into perspective for you
because you go I could be doing
something you know and the Cuban culture
on Mondays we light a candle for the
people and I have a spirit altar of all
the friends I have to the gun whether
it's carmine Bolzano whether it's
stomachs Pesci how Anthony Balsamo
Kirti Lorenzo Rey go I had a picture of
all those friends of mine my mother my
father my friend's kid had a friend who
her daughter was undergraduate on them
on the salary and got killed in a drunk
crash on a Thursday they sent me the
invite to the party I got the invite as
they were burying this girl so I've
always had her picture up and my point
is every Monday before the [ __ ] day
starts before I do anything I change
water for them I light a candle for them
and as I'm putting the glasses of water
I say today I'm gonna live for you well
this week I'm gonna live for you I look
I have a friend of a bodybuilder friend
of mine that all I gotta do is look up
and there he is with three cats that are
friends of mine two of those guys are
dead two of those guys together with
dead one of them dropped both of them
from drugs you know and I sit there I
look at them and I go to hang out live
for them for what they couldn't do how
lucky am i that I get the opportunity
and I did as many drugs as they did mmm
in fact I was with them a lot of nights
how lucky am i that I'm getting
opportunity to go do what I need to do
today but they're gone so for today I'm
gonna do it for that let's go remember
that movie Coco that came out a couple
years ago about yeah the dead that
animated but I loved that movie and the
whole thing about the photos of deceased
people that you love so because of that
movie I saw that I only saw it like last
year sometime
I took the all these great photos I have
of my dad and my sister and I made like
I wouldn't call it a shrine but I mean I
put them on this little wall next to my
kitchen where my counter is we're like
you know I put my keys and all my
business I gotta take care of it right
there you leave I'll see them every time
before you leave everyday and if you see
them when you come in it sit and you tap
your hand on the table it gives me I
don't know I just gives you peace inner
peace yes no more and it reminds me from
you know make the most out of your life
today not to forget about those people
yeah you had to had the picture up by
midnight or they were gonna take him
somewhere else so he couldn't cross the
bridge yeah that's what it was Coco that
they couldn't cross the bridge I'm
watching this I felt like daughter at
love she's loved it but I'm seeing it
from a dull adult perspective that I
live under that rule I live under that
rule for me to have life I have to give
light to the people before me I think
about my father every day that poor
bastard I think about my mother how the
[ __ ] she blew her life without ball and
betting on the Mets you know who the
[ __ ] bets on the Mets you deserve to die
and that's my mother
I'm 86 that was a good man I'm like
Jenna she she she went down in flames in
73
she went down in that flame rose the
Cincinnati Reds went to New York and
Pete Rose ended up beating up butternut
Harrelson that took a full [ __ ] life
that time so it's just uh you know you
look at those people leading you go I'm
living for that [ __ ] thing you
know Josh Adam eyes is gonna be on on
Wednesday mmm Josh Adam eyes is uh he's
a nice kid I really like him you know
we're not super tight but you know why I
love the [ __ ]
the survivor because he dedicated his
life change when Angelo died whose angel
Angelo was the best friend well an
eighth of nine years ago I guess were
they in the car together
yeah there were no there were open my
careers together and a drunk driver hit
the car mmm and killed Angelo he lives
well
just kidding on a [ __ ] mission I have
to respect somebody like that yeah
Josh Adam whatever my ex Myers were
always a good kid I loved his voice
that's such a great voice he'll always
have a a chair of my table hmm because
he did some that a lot of people don't
know and I'd remember what I did at his
goddamn jam I pulled them aside let go
Angela's watching down on your thug
you're making him [ __ ] proud you know
I might be mad at Josh atomize for my
respect level because he turned his life
around and said I'm not doing this for
me yeah I'm doing this for Angelo this
is what Angelo [ __ ] and there's certain
people do that and do it with a [ __ ]
word on their chest and you have to
respect those people and that's what
I've done that's what might I do a
one-man show at The Comedy Store and
that's what the theme is to him I'm
doing this I did this my mother's will
had one my lad one [ __ ] thing for me
yes she wanted me to be in the army and
she wanted me to be an attorney that was
great
but the main thing she wanted me to be
was to me a man what does a man do is it
be the people does he have 50
girlfriends no there's a certain way a
man or axe there's a certain way a man
presents himself there's a certain way a
man talks about or two people that's
what she wanted out of me well it took
me 50 years to get there but I got there
yeah do you understand me like if my dad
and my sister if they to live if I would
still be [ __ ] up and I don't know you
know like maybe they died so I could
have this life change you know I don't
know well you know the thing there's
people who let things go by them and
there's people who take every sign and
do something with it
God gives you signs every day he gives
you stupid [ __ ] signs every day well
I say god I'm lying to you the universe
whoever it is Gandhi Mohammed was the
other guy that white people like Buddha
no that's Chinese what so what's the one
just eat without Ming they say roll with
it
everybody's got a philosopher my
philosophy is the universe the universe
will give you the signs you need little
by little they'll give you the science
and you'll see him miss him and then you
go [ __ ] he told me two weeks ago on that
stop sign that bump said vote Andrew
yang I [ __ ] that way I went with Joe
Biden will Andrew yang the black guy in
the corner told me you get signs and you
see him sometimes in movies with a
director or show you and after getting a
sign from something just from something
you know rocky when he goes that night
to the arena and he sees that his shorts
he says the promoter hey look at the
[ __ ] shorts they're wrong my shorts
are red with blue these are blue with
red from yellow lucidum takes a puff
officer gone he goes does it really
matter
we know you to make him a good fight
that little sentence made Rocky almost
kill Apollo yeah he almost killed me
almost [ __ ] you know what's the
speech rocky gives in rocky for to Dolph
Lundgren at the end theorem and the ring
tremendous about how come if two guys
can't get together why can't our country
if I can respect you at the end the RAM
what's a great speaker gives it the dog
everyone at the end of Rambo because
America is how come America doesn't love
it as America doesn't love us as much as
we love it you know all those little
things makes leave the movie feeling
like I want to beat up a [ __ ] Spanish
dude
I'm gonna go beat up what I'm third no
third world nation he's got a new one
out but I really want you to watch it I
want him to make Cobra to the one Co all
the members God loved cover and he had
the matchstick that wasn't evil anybody
that [ __ ] car he had it was like a
1948 Ford and that was god-awful that
was a lot of cocaine I think it just
does well somebody game like a pound the
coke and said at Sloan's best film and
really I'm kidding oh my god but I do
love that movie because he looks so cool
and that car was so bad at a blonde the
whole thing I just hated that whole
thing that whole thing was just oh yeah
didn't he have his wife and then yeah
that's why it was cocaine involved and
[ __ ] in an [ __ ] weavings and you
know I left them alone who knew she was
gonna end up with flavor flavor yeah and
I just had a baby oh you're kidding me
she's like in 50 yeah she just had a kid
she did something miraculously went to
like Spain and they got that [ __ ]
bull hauling sperm over there yeah I
needed a guy go take a little [ __ ]
PPC I'm saying you need a pee piece yeah
we got a great weekend this week I
forgot to tell you guys
me and George Perez will be up in
Bakersfield Friday night at the Fox
Theater
I think the tower deed is already sold
out and then January 25th
my friend and I Steve's DeSimone will be
in Atlanta Tabernacle theatres for the
second show the first shows gonna flow
down second shows at 9:30 and there you
have it so don't ask me about the
[ __ ] dates later cuz I don't know I'm
lucky I remember this [ __ ] now it's
Monday the 13th we're just trying to
[ __ ] keep this year together a lot of
weird things happen this week in the NFL
that was no blacks while I tell you
[ __ ]
you never see a bookie with a part-time
job nobody expected to see Tennessee
beat New England at home and then going
to [ __ ] Baltimore to back the [ __ ]
big that running back you know it
too much so this is why I'm saying to
you if you haven't done anything of my
book you start having some fun this
might be that weekend for you okay I
never bet I mean it just is never my
thing but there's certain sporting
events that you can't avoid I'm nuts
about the World Cup so the last World
Cup
I bet $100 on France to win and then my
mother's from Argentina so I put $100 in
Argentina and France won and I won like
600 bucks couldn't believe it
would you put the book out of the
bedroom when I was at the MGM okay in
Vegas you're still traveling not as much
as I was you know I'm doing about only
one or two weeks a month on the road I I
what I just did
I was home in Orlando with The Improv I
got I'm doing I'm going to Europe in
June and other than that I'm just
focusing on LA in New York and staying
in the States do you keep your status
left this year
or did he no no actually this is the
last month they send me down to the
platinum oh no yeah I just can't do it
anymore I'm getting older my body's to
be on all these flights down I on
Tuesday I will be 53 53 this is Tuesday
tomorrow
yep the 40 yeah happy birthday - thank
you my brother have you what do you feel
at 53 I'm just curious what do you I did
something in December that it stayed
with me for three days
I did I ate Thanksgiving with my family
I had a great day with them gone on the
red-eye what the Fort Lauderdale did
four shows in Miami
flew back Sunday and then that Wednesday
took another 6 a.m. flight to New York
it was a 6-hour flight did the townhome
the two shows - katraine the Boston and
then blue crew back from Boston it took
me three days to recover I mean I still
did the podcast I was still a dad my
heart man and I still went to the store
on a Tuesday night yeah but Thursday was
when I finally felt
like oh well I still lifted on Monday I
still did all my regular activities it
just felt a little bit [ __ ] heavier
like it was like wow I'm what do you
feel it now our two flights a week
getting for you yet back to back I mean
it is cuz I've been you know I've been
flying so much the last couple years
especially you not came out with that
new album this she last year called
around the world and I recorded it in 24
cities around the world starts in Paris
ends in Jerusalem so really the last
couple years I was obsessed with making
this album and I was obsessed with it
and that diamond status on Delta which
also you know my wife decided she didn't
want to travel anymore so that kind of
was when we you know started to lose our
connection and everything but it takes a
lot out on your body you know I got back
in neck problems and I just can't do it
like I used to and I want to focus right
now also I did a tour of England last
year I did England Ireland and Scotland
a really great tour and I recorded those
shows so I'm gonna come out with another
album in a couple months probably called
the honky motherland from from that tour
but I mean I've focused so hard on the
international stuff for the last however
many years I really want to focus on the
States
I'm loving living in Los Angeles I've
got a new girlfriend
she's 25 I'm 53 I never wanted to be the
divorce guy with the younger girlfriend
but I'm not complaining and I'm like
really happy in my life and I love you
know I you know like we talked about
comedies my religion it's my political
party it's all I give a [ __ ] about I
don't care about anything else I'm
switching up this year I'm doing the
road till May I'm doing stand-up till
May I got I'm doing an all Spanish show
oh you told me that I have 17 I mean
I'll speak English well yeah me on
Sunday night two shows 79 well and in
june/july i'ma just do a story
tell it to that's it four shows one and
a half hours of stories do you think
that'll be your next special will be all
stories no I just want to switch it up
because if not I'll shoot myself yes
Olga sty got a San Diego date there's
something I want to go see in August the
last two we saw August why travel I'm
not competing with vacationers and kids
right and then September I gotta hit it
heavy the first week the soprano movie
comes out of the 25th I got a couple
dates with Joe you know I got a Philly
but I'll do stand-up again instead of
what I want to do is put what I'm doing
now onto a CD get away that said that
said it's been six months I'm doing this
[ __ ] material adding to it power bar
let's get rid of it let's let's down
this [ __ ] thing start from scratch
this week and then have hopefully 2030
by May give it a breather again you know
I'm trying to write this one-man show
which I perform at the store the third
Wednesday of every month I do segments
of it because I'm trying to cut it down
to two hours in which room belly roll I
mean this one-man show could I got a
kind I can keep you there for 22 hours
[ __ ] put IVs in everybody and I'll
[ __ ] I'll do Chappelle I gotta you
know my life story those 22 hours in
Gaza but I think an epic story if I take
a left turn so what I'm doing is I'm
gonna I'm writing all this [ __ ] for this
one-man show but obviously I'm not gonna
be able to use it I gotta get to the
meat and potatoes of this one-man show
for me to start working it out I think
after the comi store I'll pick a little
money and I see theater and and and uh
you know highway something 99-seat right
now in Lancashire where were we bumped
into each other when we went to see
Lenny Bruce oh yeah yeah yeah that was
like something like that yeah listen I'm
not looking to break the bank I'm
looking to existing expression two
different things yeah
fifty [ __ ] seven years old you know I
vote I won I got into this because I
like John Leguizamo specials but I
bought all of them like I have I have
whatever specter Rahman book if they
just put out Latin for morons I'm not
insulting John Leguizamo but it's the
same [ __ ] he put out 20 years ago yeah
I'm sure at this point I could put away
better one man show up and he's got it
at Studio 54 - it allows a ticket yeah I
don't even want to charge - allows the
ticket I just gonna tell my story at a
small theater in New York every [ __ ]
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday whatever just
to have a little residency I want to do
something different man yeah I want to
do something outside the box
I love the podcast I'm never gonna not
do the podcast because you're not having
your word out there on a weekly just
hurt you you gotta get out there every
week and let him know whatever you feel
if negative positive whatever the [ __ ]
you feeling because maybe they're
feeling the same thing - well and you go
through it together
- look through a [ __ ] wire look at
this this is it yeah this is it I know
what you're saying though I got Ben I
think I might have talked to you about
this but I've been I'm almost finished
with this book abandoned was inspired by
the around the world album and it's all
my my relationship to all these
different cities around the world and
it's my best stories of traveling around
the world like almost drowning in
Thailand I'm almost finished with
writing about taking my mother my
internal jesus-freak mother to Jerusalem
last year that'll probably be the last
chapter in the book so sometime later
this year I want to do something like
that
- a an hour one-man show that are just
my stories of traveling around the world
sit so I want to publish the book first
and then do it and like you're saying
not I'm not even thinking of turning it
into a moneymaker I'm thinking of doing
it in small little theaters just to do
something different this to do is I look
I'm 57 February 19th and we gotta record
these stories for posterity
I don't know I'm doing an audio boom
book I am doing an audio book we're just
working out the details right now I'm
very excited to do this because there's
no reason for me to have a hardcover
Barnes and Noble you know Elvis is dead
apartment oh boy they're doing that good
anyway it was a dream of mine to see a
book of me on the shelf
but I'm not a good writer I'm not alive
the patience to write I don't know about
TV anymore yeah you know it's got to be
the right [ __ ] gig
and I'm very happy where I am you know
right now but a processor I'm trying to
raise a seven-year-old girl to get her
ready for this [ __ ] Avenue of doom
but I put her on you know if over the
world wasn't gonna be in this shape I
wouldn't a shot a load of nobody I will
Shiloh the [ __ ] hell but you know you
gotta get your kids ready for today's
world it's a different [ __ ] world
yeah that's what I'm trying to do Tom
Rhodes you know and it's great that
thank you how many guys we started with
it
we have long talks with and they told us
about this in this these guys are out of
the business [ __ ] or not not to put
anybody down on a cruise ship you know
or they're doing something completely
out of their realm which they started
doing because now they have to [ __ ]
pay a mortgage I'll tell you something
being a slave to a mortgage are you a
slave to your [ __ ] things you own
that's a horrible way to live I'd rather
[ __ ] live to keep the nut low keep
everybody low keep everybody happy and
mmm that's it that's why I'm at this
point in my life I'm just looking you
know 70 is the new 50 but we got we
still have 13 years on this Mike I know
I do I know I do there's gonna be pieces
of hair fall off my nose no look like
Artie Lange's saying my head's gonna be
all [ __ ] up but I'll still be here
doing this podcast with an IV on because
I don't give a [ __ ] I'll be doing live
about me you know I might the pedophile
with the voice box I'm gonna see if a
pedophile were the boys boxing [ __ ] come
in handy
then he goes this pocket his batteries
from the voice box it's a [ __ ]
nightmare
you're still be doing ass and taking out
you probably put stuff in the IV I
really know I you know it just I ate is
just a number and the III popped into
the Comedy Store last month and John
Waters was doing a show in the in the in
the main room and apparently he doesn't
show there once a year I love John
Waters and he I talked to him afterwards
who Thursday's ago yeah yeah maybe two
Thursday's ago cuz I was like what the
[ __ ] is he doing I couldn't believe it I
couldn't believe what he and I I - I old
is he now 70 because I know this because
or 71 because he wrote a book about four
or five years ago about hitchhiking
across America from Baltimore to San
Francisco John Waters and I read it and
he's like people are like are you John
Waters you look like John Waters it
seems like a you know pretty distinctive
looking cat with his you know Boris yeah
the mustache and he I said hey man I I
love that book and he said I just wrote
another book about doing acid at 70 so
that's what his new book is about do or
the acid at 70 mmm
that must be very interesting I haven't
done acid in years Jesus a couple times
I've done the acid that's run through me
it's been good acid but it hasn't taken
me Oh
open that door I'm gonna go pee I can't
imagine any ask that you did then
because I've grown up with you a couple
times they charge me crazy did you I was
wondering um did you watch that PBS
thing the Mark Twain thing about
Chappelle I did it was brilliant I just
thought a couple nights ago I was really
great and I saw Neal Brennan last night
and I told him how how incredible I
thought he was on it oh yeah I thought I
thought it was uh very inspired I
thought it was cool the way because like
we you guys were talking how not every
not everyone has a great reputation and
everyone everyone loved him and then
just the thing the speech he had at the
end about how it's an art and how you
know
that I thought was just very I'm glad
you brought that up because he said I
may not agree with every practitioner of
this genre but I know where they're
coming from
they wouldn't they have an idea they
want to be understood they want to be
heard I thought that speech was
beautiful
yeah it was uh and then him having his
mom there like I I I'm well I just hit
two years and I always say when I was
watching that I teared up a little bit
because Joey had let me let me open for
him a year ago in the with the Bluebird
theater which is my growing up in Boston
was like the biggest theater yeah and I
said a joke that I never said ever again
and I've never said before I won't never
say again and I heard my mom laugh like
I just just like like that uh that gift
that Joey gave me was pretty amazing it
having that memory of my mom laughing in
the Wilber Theatre your mom seeing you
at the Wilbur theater party Austin Cory
you know it's a it's like as much as
like this is fun and all that it's it is
pretty amazing what it gives us okay and
I'm brand-new and I'm nowhere near
anywhere you guys are well I had the I
had the greatest you know III did this
tour of Israel and you have to be
squeaky clean to do this tour and I you
know I only had to do 20-minute set so I
was really nervous about it I was like
thinking of old jokes and like uh you
know turned out not to be a problem but
the last gigs on this tour were in
Jerusalem and I brought my mother over
there with me you know we flew over a
week early and just to give her that
experience huge you know Jesus woman
who's prayed for me her whole life and
then the best shows of that entire tour
were in Jerusalem and this beautiful
theater like modern theater and there
was like a 7 p.m. show for the older
people and then there was like a 10:00
p.m. show for the younger people and my
mom sat in that audience and got to see
me destroying in where this the city
where Jesus did his best work if I'm one
of the proudest moments of my life you
know and then I what I was worried about
the the clean material wasn't a problem
it's like when I travel around the world
to different countries usually what you
losing reference you gained an
observation so like I had these great
stories about about just my experience
with my mom in Jerusalem or in Israel
like I told the story on stage in
Jerusalem it's um it's on my album on
the The Jerusalem track where when I was
16 years old I was dumped by my high
school sweetheart and my mother and I
had to walk around Lake charm in Oviedo
Florida hundreds of times before I even
started to feel a little bit better and
then here we were 35 years later walking
along the Mediterranean Sea in Tel Aviv
reliving this exact same moment because
I was going through my divorce and I
realized at that moment that I think my
mother is the love of my life and he
should have heard this audience
especially the older audience at 7 p.m.
in Jerusalem just go oh you know so but
I I'm glad you brought that up
isn't watching that Joey the PBS thing
that Chappelle did know it was pretty
interesting too brilliant and it's great
that he did a set it to come the improv
in DC the night before the way they cut
in that then like old performance
footage of him I thought it was it was
um PBS knocked it out of the park with
that I'd only accepted an award the
market or the market word which is
that's like that's the Pulitzer Prize
for a comedian you know the first
comedian ever to win the Mark Twain
Award was Richard Pryor you know and
they do it at the Lincoln Center it's a
big deal
and I love the fact that he he honored
Tony woods and you know do you know Tony
I've known Tony is such a beautiful guy
in the business and everybody said
forever that you know Chappelle you know
learned how to do stand-up from him and
Chapelle takes the moment to say and the
thing you know you know Miles Davis was
copy and dizzy gillespie and if I'm
Miles Davis I was copying you you know
you were that you were the first
comedian I ever saw who was doing it
right the way it was supposed to be you
were honest and fearless and you know
it's really great it's uh it makes you
really I come
when I got into comedy the level I
thought I was gonna make it to was the
level of the comics that couldn't make
it because of their alcohol their drug
abuse problems you know I'm saying
please
there's a thousand of those I knows yeah
the room that you know they just travel
to get high and that that's it then yeah
they think if you live in LA and you're
gay if you play The Improv you're a
corporate sellout they have an excuse
for every level of what you're doing
Tommy except for what they're doing
meanwhile they're playing like moon
Chuck's comedy room and [ __ ] bum [ __ ]
bum [ __ ] it's just like I'm honored
to be where I'm at right now like
nobody's more grateful than I am I feel
the same way
[ __ ] I am I'm not the most famous but
I'm so grateful for what I have I know
where I came from so when they call my
name optical in the aerodrome like oh my
god can I [ __ ] my way through this
you know like you know I only I know
[ __ ] I am
that's why I've never caught on to know
this [ __ ] end of it you know I watched
the Kevin Hart thing on Netflix I love
Kevin wouldn't want to be Kevin I
wouldn't have watched it - it says what
do you want to be Cal that's a different
life economy that I like I told you last
night
my my utopia for comedy was living at
the Chelsea shooting the heroine doing
comedy in between strippers like Lenny
Bruce when I read that I go I could
accept that there was no TV there there
was no friends I don't want to be
Seinfeld
that had nothing doing all that [ __ ] you
know how I ended up here and what I was
completely different yeah but that's
where my head is that as a comic well I
took I had that experience cuz Mitch
Hedberg lived it the Chelsea 98 to 2000
when I was living in a wall stream it's
been he died in 2005 so it's 15 years
now March he died a March it'll be 15
years of March
so Edberg was one of my best friends in
that period and we've done a ton of coke
at the Chelsea if we run at the Chelsea
we're at my Rockstar apartment in the
Wall Street area was after my sitcom at
tons of cash and just you know yet like
two guitars in his room at the Chelsea
we'd sit up all night you know drinking
and sniffing and or we'd be down in Wall
Street at my place playing music and
dancing on furniture bringing people
back that we met after the shows and
stuff it was a lot of fun so I had that
trick that Chelsea Hotel drug experience
out then it was great man cuz you know
and all there's like did they redo
whether it might no no it's so gritty it
was still gritty I mean there were some
rooms that were nicer than others we got
invited to some other people's rooms
there were you know there was some
bigger suite rooms on the higher floors
but you know all in the lobby and up
down the staircase were all these
fantastic paintings by you know artists
who had lived there that couldn't pay
their rent that gave them art you know
and just so much great artistic history
there it's been quite a ride huh Bravo
yeah it doesn't end I mean I feel like
I'm I'm I'm I'm moving into the the best
period of my life and in my comedy so am
i you know so crazy cuz I know I've had
so much experiences and I have so much
wisdom and knowledge now you know that I
did for my it's it's so way now I
learned so much about what you know when
I came in Lee was talking about he went
out but the world but theater you know
in front of his mom and it was great and
this year I was I was gonna do the the
other theatre Sheva where theater and I
thought real hard I go am I gonna take
Ali with me and I thought about it
really hard and then we came to me and
asked them I going with you and I think
this Steve Simone and I go I don't want
to take you to that theater anymore and
I felt really guilty about it because I
know it would be his time to see his mom
and I want to see his mom
but I want Lee to see the journey I felt
I didn't do theaters at the trillion
mark nobody took me to a [ __ ] theater
yeah nobody took me to a deed until the
seven year mark and I [ __ ] die the
slow death
I think Lee needs to see the journey of
this because I'll help him with all the
other areas of his life you know and I
think that's what this comedy career for
me was uh it was a whole therapeutic 25
year it took me to find out who the [ __ ]
I was on what my voice was about and
what I really wanted you know that's
hard it's really hard to look at
yourself in the mirror and go what do I
really want you know I'm like a friend
of mine said you got to write it down
seven times and then give yourself the
answer you know now is what and it
wasn't me writing it down seven times
that's a great way of doing it it was
taking the journey this is a journey man
you know and the comedy journey is the
manhood journey or the womanhood journey
or the story of the woman that has to
adjust to live in a man's world to do
[ __ ] Tom me like Whitney Cummings and
and you know all the great female comics
have had a cut their [ __ ] awful put
scotch tape over it or scotch tape their
own dick to do comedy and that's where I
want the lead it wasn't I didn't want to
take them with me if I want him to see
this journey that I saw this journey
that I saw you have to see you have to
see this journey I saw to appreciate
that 9:15 spot yeah exactly Commodore
gene have you ever read Joseph Prince
the hero with a thousand faces no
apparently George Lucas took a lot of
this guy's teachings and put it into the
original Star Wars that's why it's got
this the story is broken down the way it
is but this guy he was a mythology
expert an ancient culture expert this
guy studied stories from ancient Greek
theater store to studied all the
religions
Theater the history of theater up to
contemporary cinema ending with the
movie star wars so the hero with a
thousand faces basically says that
everyone we ever considered a hero
in the Bible in stories and movies in
any kind of situation in storytelling
the the the story of the hero always
have us as a similar pattern the hero
was on his way on his journey rising up
and then something knocked him down that
he had to overcome him or her and had to
rise had to overcome some major setback
or some major heart back or or even
death in Jesus's story that everyone we
ever considered a hero never went
straight up to the top all the way
people who rise and never deal with
problems aren't people we consider
heroes it's always the people who
overcame some major [ __ ] setback in
their journey to rise back up so I think
you're absolutely right listen this this
is this journey of being a comic taught
me how to be a comic but it taught me
how to be a man hey Green me too taught
me how to be a real man then I became
the comic and then everything smooth and
about you know I was noticing last night
the County store there's no negative
energy up there no more you walk in the
hall where you see Chris D'Elia talking
to Whitney yeah there's somebody else
you hug them you're giggling and it's
exciting man I like seeing Helen I like
I like studying the Masters and seeing
what other people are doing it's just an
exciting time listen man I'm a happy
took the time out to come on up today
and share your beautiful [ __ ] I love
you with all my heart Joey deals you
tomorrow what do you got coming up and
thanks for being uh thanks for being my
friend you know especially last year
when I was going through my divorce man
you know anybody can be a good friend on
the when everything's happy amen if you
want good friends you got to be a good
friend and that's the [ __ ] tomorrow
today's Monday morning forecast January
13th 2000 the day before my birthday
before you what do you got planned for
your birthday my friend yeah I bothered
the store yeah that would be the best
that's possible birthday just so you get
this door yeah I'll be at the store will
be at the store I got and I'll be
everywhere all over there you know
America is here I think comedy chaos is
next week yeah no counting I'm I'm on
calmly chaos this week with Tripoli and
tonight I'm down have you done it
tonight if you're going there yeah I'll
be down there I'm always down listen oh
yeah we didn't get to talk about Bikram
yoga I thought it was funny let's go
that was great you talked about that
documentary right he did it showed the
new discussed the bike that he is this
is yo the Scott's bag that he is 15
years ago when I was living in LA I
started I was doing Bikram yoga there
was a bunch of comedian friends of mine
they were into it and I don't like to
exercise but it was like you know full
of it it just it's hot it's in a hundred
degrees you're sweating your balls off I
enjoyed it I did the you know I I did it
at the what was the headquarters and he
came in and taught a class once because
Indian television people television from
India was was filming him and it was a
really small class and some LA dude in
the in the class pours water on his head
and the guy Bikram yells at him what are
you doing in my own the guy he when I
pulled in I saw him pullin at the same
time in his Rolls Royce and he was so he
starts grandstanding in front of the
television cameras for India what are
you doing wasting water pouring water on
your head in my country people have to
walk ten miles to get some more fresh
water and he was just totally doing it
for the television cameras and I'm
thinking well you know why don't you
sell the rolls and build a [ __ ]
viaduct that could get fresh water to
your village that you abandoned you know
it was like kind of pretentious la stuff
but like they say in the docq
it was a great exercise and it was their
ancient yoga poses and and just for the
stretching of the spine most people get
back problems as they get older I
wouldn't mind getting back into some
kind of yoga just to like just to twist
the spine around so it's good for you
it's just a way he took over LA he took
over LA like Harvey Weinstein it was
like you were talking before there was
people that wouldn't call him out and he
was like you know liberal la female sin
feminists there and like that guy was
you know well that's the home to those
[ __ ] knuckleheads see that's the home
see I got approached by them at a party
where a chick said to me he it's not
just the exercise he touches you inside
and I'm looking at it going you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] but if you notice
everything in LA everything in Hollywood
is it listen let me get this out of the
way right now for you [ __ ] just
see you know what time it is when New
York sneezes everybody catches a cold
the party comes out in New York don't
ever let that mistake you at all the
party started in New York and the
party's always gonna be in New York LA
he's got this different thing you know
the adesh so you know Marky Wahlberg
credits his body to jumpin jacks and f45
so what's that 45 45 was a new circle
schools around the country where they're
doing it completely different like for
years we've been doing it right now
we're doing it wrong so now because
marking Wahlburgers is doing it that's
probably a thousand people going up
there yeah you gotta see this [ __ ] you
know resistance day rainbow day flowered
day we go on phases when I got here in
97 of his taibo everybody was kicking on
the streets even if he went into 7/11
there was a Hindu back there throwing
tae-bo lessons for two hours the morning
what happened to tae bum went out in a
tie but we just we are the suckers for
everything here in LA yeah we are
suckers you know and now New York has
that type of civilization that
that young wanna la B so they'll get it
I'll get it too and they'll pay 285 a
month when they can just go to the Y and
do forty four dollars and protect all
the classes and get the same benefits
they got from law 45 you know you always
it's so weird like III don't go to the
gym I'm trained you know yeah because
you want to be different than everybody
else that's that's all actors ever want
to do is show you the how they're
different you know well Jennifer Lopez's
body you know I wonder who our trainer
is the same one that's in your town same
[ __ ] idiot don't eat and do jumping
jacks that's Jennifer Lopez yeah okay
yeah I'm sayin
there was a very effeminate instructor
that'd be wrong Bikram at governor's
years ago he wasn't the main guy there
was another guy that was like yeah yeah
you know I only saw the become teach the
thing once but like you some of these
people you know it's hot you know some
people barely wear anything so some
people would go in and only wear
underwear and this very effeminate
Indian instructor one day goes I just
want to say like in the middle of class
yeah they just want to say some of you
men who insist on coming in here in your
underwear what is that this is a holy
sanctuary and it should be respected as
that you you there and the Calvin Klein
striped underwear do you think we want
to see that I'm gay and I don't want to
see that how does this [ __ ] guy just
chopped off this dude you full of [ __ ]
they're a lottery man alright listen
you're full of [ __ ] that's a prime
[ __ ] [ __ ] for you think you
[ __ ] lottery ticket sales nice little
white guy with a tight [ __ ] and
you're telling me you're a friend it go
[ __ ] yourself they're all a bunch of
[ __ ] liars at the end of the week
these [ __ ] lottery salesmen
how could they find you though oh i @
underscore Tom Rhodes on Instagram Tom
Rhodes net and buy my album around the
world will be around the store next
couple weeks yeah I'll be around yeah
mom yeah I'm I'm around a lot the next
couple months
I can't wait to [ __ ] see you're right
you're good when you're around it takes
the [ __ ] ego level down at this store
you know I'm saying you're right about a
good vibe man it's really no it's really
you know a great vibe there the last
four years they got rid of everybody
that was a [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody
that would go in there look at Tom
Rhodes and go why is he here you know
like that those type of people we're
here because we're comics but yeah you
know it was even great to see cuz me and
Neil got into it for a while he would
break my balls
he would go are you gonna use structure
tonight or you just gonna go up there
and you know so then I would go to him
Neil teaching me structure what are you
gonna teach me how to do structure I
don't know nothin bad man yeah and even
him last night I gave him the biggest
hug and pick them up and kissed him and
ya told them that you never and he
doesn't like to touch people know so
those guys I was cool that you guys
hugged what yeah I brought you on why
don't you off the season visa is a
potato guys welcome not a handshake guys
no show exam okay we were in the hugging
business now we got I don't have that
much time left in the world these hugs
count you have my daughter give you a
hug and come over the house of my
seven-year-old give young I'd love it
all your problems will disappear they
all disappear for three minutes you know
what the [ __ ] is this talk about and so
I'm looking forward to going home and
getting a [ __ ] hug anyway but most
importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] for always having our back
do not forget Friday night Bakersfield
with George Perez Fresno the tickets are
sold I listen you get on a bicycle
taking the right to Bakersfield if not
you're [ __ ] alright that's it and
that's that
we'll be back Thursday morning ready to
rock and roll with you [ __ ] I
want to thank my brother Tom Rhodes I
want to thank the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] don't forget Atlanta 25th
of January 9:30
there's still some tickets left you know
take the drive I don't give a [ __ ] it's
just snow
take a chance Columbus did get a bottle
of blackberry brandy and get out there
in the snow and see where it takes you
some saying somebody is my end up that's
no embarkment and the other ones in the
put a DUI but what the [ __ ] you doing
with your life anyway a couple of nights
in the pokey Britt builds character I
love you brother [ __ ] this thank you
very much for listening and see